foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones
in-house of the Dragon update video in
this video I want to go over all the new
information regarding House of the
dragon's second season HBO will begin
filming House of the Dragons new season
any day now we're most likely only days
away from things getting very exciting
in the Game of Thrones Universe once
again as I have said before once filming
begins on House of the Dragon over these
next few weeks we will begin to see a
lot new photos and videos from the set
we already know HBO has been looking for
new actors for some of House of the
dragon's biggest scenes next season Once
filming begins and we start to see the
actors on set during the scenes we will
learn what will be happening in the
second season I'm assuming a lot of you
already have a good idea of what will
happen in the second season if you've
read Fire and Blood now although House
of the Dragon is using Fire and Blood as
an outline George RR Martin recently
said the second season will make some
more deviations from his novel as of
right now it's hard to say if this is a
good or bad thing without knowing which
direction they will go in however it's
you usually not a very good idea to
deviate from George RR Martin's original
writing the new article goes on to say
there may be less Fire and Blood display
during House of the dragon's second
season as HBO show co-creators hinted
more deviations from George R Martin's
acclaimed novel Martin and fellow House
of the Dragon Creator Ryan Condell spoke
at HBO's fyc event on March 7th delving
into a few tidbits about the show and
what viewers can look forward to in the
show's follow-up season George R Martin
insisted Fire and Blood served as an
outline for House of the Dragon though
this show fits in bits and pieces rather
than large chunks it was an imaginary
history book that has a few scenes where
I zero in and I give you half a page of
a scene but mostly it's history it's an
outline and you can only show an outline
on television so it has to be filled in
he said in Fire and Blood for example it
has stated that Emma Aaron dies in
childbirth and the son dies the
following day there is nothing about it
being the most horrendous childbir scene
ever seen on TV he's certainly right
about that as horrific as that scene
might have been I think it was an
amazing addition to George R Martin's
writing I wouldn't necessarily say this
as a deviation however because it still
had the same end result George R Martin
described the show as an adaptation but
also a creation Ryan Condell meanwhile
revealed there will be five new dragons
in House of the dragon's second season
with George R Martin admitting he was
impressed by how believable the fire
breathers look during season one they
had personality he said they came alive
it came as a great satisfaction to me as
for when filming season 2 begins Ryan
Condell said it would begin shortly as I
said earlier in the video filming will
begin any day now we should start to see
photos and videos of the actors on set
filming their scenes very soon I know
I'm certainly ready to start making
several new videos every week again
alright now on deadlines recent article
House of the Dragon showrunner Ryan
condle drops a hint about what to expect
in season two as recently mentioned we
will see five new dragons in House of
the Dragon second season unfortunately
he did not say which ones however I
think I can make an educated guess there
was a dragon shown in the first season
of Elsa the dragon that was never
officially given an introduction and
that was aegon's Dragon Sunfire now that
aegon sits on the iron throne and the
dance of the Dragons is about to be
underway we are going to meet a lot new
dragons in the following Seasons aegon's
Dragon Sunfire will definitely be one of
the standouts not only because it's
aegon's Dragon but also because we will
see him fly his Dragon into battle
alongside his brother's Dragon the
massive Sea Dragon vegar there's also
several wild dragons living on
Dragonstone during the dance of the
Dragons rhaenyra will look for New
Riders for those dragons their sheep
stealer Cannibal and gray ghost not to
mention there's also Silverwing who was
once written by Queen alisane Targaryen
there is several other smaller dragons
as well who were written by the kids
like dream fire Moon Dancer anti-raxis
just to name a few it will be
interesting to see how they start adding
these new dragons into the fold the sky
above King's Landing and Dragonstone is
about to be filled with fire-breathing
dragons and I for one cannot wait with
all of the new information about to be
releasing every day I will begin to
start making several videos every week
again make sure you subscribe so you can
be the first to know what's happening
with House of the dragon and all of the
other Game of Thrones successor shows as
always I want to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
thank you